Quanah has only been alive for 51 days
she's now part of the migrant Caravan
hoping to get to the United States but
you can't move anywhere now I've only
known her for three days and in that
time she's gone from having a light
cough to intensive care
her mother Melinda is sleeping in the
ward now caring for her baby relieved
that Juana is being treated by the
Mexican authorities and was convinced
that she will stabilize we first met the
family in the camp a few days ago they
have no idea if they will get asylum in
the United States Melinda's evidence
sent her gang member brother to jail for
life his gang wanted her dead
I joined dad client as he retrieved a
few essentials for the night in hospital
tell me that the camp is getting worse
as it fills up these suspects people
will start getting increasingly unhappy
things are deteriorating quickly here as
more migrants arrive the Mexican
authorities are predicting 10,000 people
will come to Tijuana it's difficult to
imagine where they will go because this
is already full the last 24 hours the
atmosphere has completely changed there
are a lot more people this is a food
queue it's being provided by the Marines
it's going to take ages to get fed that
camp is packed I am not sure that this
is sustainable people just won't stay
here living in these conditions half of
the migrants heading north
but now stuck a children and their
camping with thousands of adults you can
hear people huffing almost constantly
they're outside and it's very cold now
it's why doctors American doctors are
saying hold on this could get very bad
indeed
we've potentially got a real
humanitarian crisis brewing here because
they've been marching and walking very
long ways but they've come to the end of
that road and so now we're in a
situation where you know it could be
very overcrowded and so public health
issues come into concern nobody is sure
what's going to happen next the United
States Asylum system is going
be really stretched by the arriving
Caravan and there are more coming
President Trump and his government are
still casting the migrants as criminals
determined to enter the US illegally but
there appears to be little evidence to
support either of those claims what is
an absolute fact though is that in these
conditions more and more will get sick
Quanah is just one of the first still
Ramsey Sky News Tijuana